نديم كيف تاثر الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي منذ
بدء عمليه طوفان الاقصى نبدا بالتاثيرات
الانيه خسائر في البورصه في تل ابيب بدات
ب 4% وانتهت ب 6% ما يعادل 20 مليار دولار
من القيمه السوقيه نعرف ان البورصه في تل
ابيب تشكل ما نسبته 54% من الناتج المحلي
الاسرائيلي هناك تعطل في حركه الملاحه
تحديدا في الطائرات القائده الى بن جوريون
هذا بالطبع سيؤثر على السياحه سيؤثر على
الحركه على التجاره تواصل اسرائيل مع
العالم بالح حركه تجاريه هذا فيما يتعلق
في الاسواق ايضا هناك الشيكل الشيكل
بالاساس هو منخفض لادنى مستوياته في سبعه
سنوات ستزيد هذه الضغوط مع وجود حاله عدم
الثقه والتوجه الناس نحو الملاذات الامنه
في ظل هذه الاوضاع غير المستقره تحديدا
على الجانب الاقتصادي الاستثمارات كما
نعلم راس المال هو جبان يخاف عند التوترات
ايضا سنجد ضغط حاليا على الاستثمارات
القادمه لاسرائيل وهي الاستثمارات التي
تناقصت بحدود 60 في في الربع الاول من هذا
العام تعطل الحياه الاقتصاديه اغلاق
القطاعات قطاعات التجاره الصناعه كل ذلك
اثاره سوف تنعكس على توقعات النمو
الاقتصادي الاسرائيلي التي كانت تصل الى
3% الان دون هذه المستويات وسنجد خلال
الايام القليله القادمه
مؤسسات الائتمان
الدوليه بالتاكيد سوف تعيد نظرتها وقراءه
في الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي البن